I mentioned this last time that you were
in great shape and it looks like you've
even improved you're in even better
shape this time what's going on oh it's
my Spanx mostly have you do you ever go
I know that you've lost a lot of weight
do you have a goal weight you're trying
to reach I don't really have a goal
weight I have a goal and that is to be
the most in-shape pro wrestling fan you
love pro wrestling and you want to be of
all the people that watch pro wrestling
at home I won't be the most likely to
get in the actual ring yeah because I
don't know if you watch a lot of pro
wrestling have you seen a lot of pro
wrestling fans but we are very sedentary
people we don't like doing a lot of the
action we just like watching it while we
eat you probably get high of those
people you will be the most in-shape are
there other benefits of being in shape
now that you've noticed oh yeah more sex
definitely driving more sex now I'm
having more and different types of sex I
had sex standing up I thought it was
just like movie special effects but you
can really pick somebody up and have sex
with them from I found for about 2.5 to
5 seconds you don't need that much time
you've got a show that you can do it
yeah and then you go let's go back to
these now my back hurts yeah go back to
the couch now now that you're nuttier
[Laughter]
you